Hello everybody welcome back to candid
Truth where the standard is not just I
mean the truth is not just optional but
the
standard um we are going to be speaking
on a topic that quite honestly deceived
me in my youth and into my adult years
and is a very important one so I hope
that you're ready for that we have my
friend and expert in this um Stephanie
Griffin uh based on her experience
with this and she's going to tell us all
about it so please welcome
her and hello Aubrey hello how are you
thank you good thank you thank you for
having me of
course
um so can you tell us just a little
snippet of how you got this
experience sure I was introduced to
spiritual formation as um a nurse
working in the hospital
by a
chaplain in the form of spiritual
Direction and so that began my nine-year
journey of spiritual formation uh into
the practices and such and then little
did I know or understand at the time I
was actually sitting in emerging Church
wow probably the most popular one that
we know yeah so yes but I didn't
recognize where I was until nine years
later even coming out of spiritual
formation and it took me a little bit to
identify oh emerging Church how they're
connected and that even looks like yes
so I felt the same way I wasn't in it
for nine years but I was in a church
that so slowly we're going to walk
through the steps of how they start
integrating these practices into the
church um but I so slowly caught on as
to what they were doing and um I did try
to confront some of the people there but
it was not successful they're usually
Steamrollers just kind of like bull you
over and they're on their way um
unfortunately but we want to know how to
avoid this deception what is the
emergent Church of course this might be
new to people completely so go ahead we
can tell us all about
it okay well uh it's there's a lot here
it's a lot to build on so I'm just going
to kind of start with the basics and
move forward for those who may not
understand it as I did not um okay so
what is the emerging church and more
than that what's it what is it what is
it and where is it supposed to take us
that's the point there is an endgame to
this and so we're going to see that so
our in our first slide uh next we will
see uh well it's important important to
understand what fundamentalism is what's
a
fundamentalist um it's a religious
movement it's characterized by strict
belief in religious interpretation of
religious text and for Christians
specifically that would be the Bible so
an example strong example of that would
be Martin Luther solar scriptura right
we dependent upon the Bible and the
Bible only to tell us who God is what
his character is and what he wants for
us right that's very important yeah it
is if if we don't use him as our basis
for everything then we lose our way and
that's what's happened with the emerging
church it's lost its way yes right okay
our next slide so to understand the the
mindset of the emerging Church model we
need to understand um the context of
where we are in society and we are in a
post-modern society so there's no truth
or error right there's
um there's no absolute truth I should
say and what's true for you that's fine
but it may not be my truth I have my
truth and we just Live and Let Live
supposedly so uh they're big on social
justice and we've seen that over the
past few years in particular different
movements coming forward very much
Social Justice the churches have
embraced a new gospel the Social Gospel
okay
next and uh morality is personal we
talked about that they are globalist not
nationalist
um when politically speaking uh Jesus
Christ is not the only way to God so
there's a pluralism that's an effect
here when when Jesus says I am the way
the truth and the life and Men come to
the father except through
me so there's a difference in
understanding there and then the next
slide uh let's see they gravitate
towards the new age and you'll see that
impact a little bit later but they're
very pro- new age things even though may
not identify them as new age they're
pro- environmentalism so they defend
Mother Earth we see a lot of Earth
worship now we see at the world economic
form bringing in um indigenous people
cultures and tribes and mother nature
and that sort of thing okay
next uh postmodernists um do not attempt
to Define their thoughts about what is
right or wrong true or false good or
evil they believe that there isn't such
a truth as absolute truth there's no
absolute okay so there's no Foundation
uh to go back to to um compare what it
is they're looking
at let's see um according to the post
modern worldview the world society is an
outdated lifestyle so we need to
modernize our thinking and make it
relevant and if you're familiar at all
with emerging Church um lingo MH
something that's relevant you make
things relevant yes so that's what they
talk about divine revelation versus
moral relativism is what we're talking
about so we either um believe what the
scriptures say or we look at the morals
of the day and say well you know this
this is right for them it's not right
for me okay next and you can stop me
anytime I just there's a lot of slides
so I'm just GNA kind of move through
this okay but talk about anything you
want to okay so ignacius lyola was a
Spanish Theologian you know that name he
was a found Society of Jesus and his
contemporary was Martin Luther and when
you look at their decisions and their
paths and their endings uh you see that
Martin Luther chose the Bible solo
scriptura he chose biblical prayer and
he started a
Reformation
lyola started the um the Jesuits and
which was a Counter Reformation movement
he chose well he is the one who
basically he was channeled he had
visions and such of these exercises and
he put them together and offered the
exercises and he practiced what they
call contemplative prayer kind of thing
which is a counterfeit to real prayer
which we will get into a little bit
later and so yeah I'm sorry I have a
question you said is that contemplative
prayer or
yes I said well I probably said
contemplative if you're contemplative
you say contemplative and I was when I
knew that's how I learned to say
it it was just how my brain was starting
to grasp it so I was like wait let's
just clarify yeah yeah you can say
Tomatoes Tomatoes right
right all right so he wrote the
spiritual exercises uh it was a dynamic
system of spiritual spirituality meaning
change it's built on change oh
and it's also a very emotional kind of
experience okay
next um so he started his uh niche in
education that's what Jesuits do they
are real big into philosophy and
psychology um and they start schools and
this is how they
evangelize they form they shape minds
and we're seeing that today the results
of that today okay next
uh let's see their focus is on the youth
because what What did the what is the
what the Catholics say give me your
youth for the first seven years and
they'll they'll be a Catholic always
something like that so they're really
into fashioning and molding the
minds an example of that and this is not
necessarily Catholic but we'll see that
contemplative prayer is the same as
meditation and mindfulness and this is
what's practiced in school school
systems from TK transitional Kinders
through fifth grade and they even teach
it higher but so there you go those are
your first first years very formative
years yes col Rainer he was oh go ahead
sorry I was just going to connect the
dots just in case anyone's been
wondering they should have been able to
see in the news even that this is a
trend that's happening in schools
meditation is being taught
heavily so I hope you guys know that but
it's it's kind of been all over so yes
and you know thanks to Goldie Han and
her mindup program she's really brought
it to the Forefront so
yeah okay next slide oh no no Carl Riner
he is the basically the the architect of
Vatican
2 and uh he was the expert and let's
see so the goals for Vatican 2 were
collaboration dialogue talk right let's
just talk to our people talk to our
separated brethren servant cooperations
this is like things like soup kitchens
joint soup kitchen efforts joint um
dental clinics um um um Foster not
Foster but um what is it when you have
children who are adopted or orphanages
yes thank you so there are a lot of
joint projects where they could not meet
the Protestant with Doctrine because
we're never going to agree we have two
different sources of text right yeah um
they they have theirs and we have ours
so then they said well we're going to
make them friends and that's what
they've done they've cultivated a
relationship which we're seeing played
out in the churches today and that's
going to be very difficult thing to turn
your back on your friend uh in the
future right and not that we want to
turn our back on our friends but to
follow truth sometimes there there has
to be a
separation yes very true all right so
call ranner oh this is not a very good
slide I'm sorry I added it today so he
says this man who was the architect of
Vatican 2 says the Christian of the
future will be a Mystic or he will not
exist at all there's a slightly Veiled
Threat there that we will see later
there's no Veil at all but this is where
we're going the Christian of the future
will be a Mystic okay but what's a
Mystic okay let's go so Vatican 2 U this
is from a Vatican Vatican VA website and
the question is did the second Vatican
Council changed the Catholic Doctrine in
the church on the church response the
second Vatican Council neither changed
nor intended to change this Doctrine
rather it developed deepened and more
fully explained it and then you go on to
more towards the bottom it says what the
church has taught down through the
centuries we also uh teach um oh what
well what was still is and then um in
simple terms that which was assumed is
now explicit and that which was
uncertain is now clarified and that
which was meditated upon discussed and
sometimes argued
over uh snow put together in one clear
formulation so be clear they have not
changed by their own admission okay
let's move forward yeah I wanted to just
um
there that you can go to the next one
it's blank um it's like she said it's
not Chang their agenda's always been the
same since the beginning of the
formation of the Catholic Church way
back
when um and I hope we're going to see
more of that but and proof of that but
it's truly been their name in general
let's just say that Catholic means World
Church yeah so yes
sorry if I busted that bubble no no
that's F you didn't say the real word
yet but that was good okay okay good
we're moving closer you can say whatever
you want fine um okay so here it says
the changes made by second Vatican
Council ending in 1965 we're in liturgy
that's the way we do worship um
administrative practices and most
important in ecumenicism this was an
ecumenical uh shift while admitting that
other churches contain elements of Truth
it repeated that the Roman Catholic
Church is the only true church that's
why they call themselves The Church okay
next I have a question real quick just
for those watching that may not
know what how would you define I guess
ecumenicism or me ecumenical
movement it's an Outreach to bring the
Protestants or whoever was we find out
into the fold back to Mother Church
right okay
yeah how we how they reach those people
yeah
yeah okay Catholic literal oh here we go
you want to say itad read it Aubrey read
it okay Catholic L literally means
Universal the protest is over said by
Tony Palmer who we now know is
supposedly deceased okay um and then
after this was after watching the Pope's
greeting on a giant screen this is when
he met with the Pentecostal leaders um
and Copeland said Thank you so uh from
the bottom of our
hearts so he and then began to speak in
tongues okay all right so to prove my
ecumenical point and because I know that
aliens are near and dear to Mikey
because he's his documentary I'm gonna
bring in like this is the most drastic
piece of ecumenical right now that I can
see aliens what did the pope say about
aliens he says Green Oh aliens which he
imagines could be green with the long
nose and big ears just like Tron paint
them should be baptized just like anyone
else who asked for it because it's not
up to any human to decide who should
receive the holy spirit so even
aliens wow and the next
slide and this to support that um this
is so father Jose funz expressed the
possibility of extraterrestrial
Brothers these your separated brethren
right here coming home yeah instead of
the mothership it's the mother church
right all right so what is the emerging
church it's a fresh and relevant way of
looking and thinking about Doctrine it's
basically a deconstruction and
reconstruction so we break down the word
of God and then we build it back up and
this is what I was told when I was
brought into spiritual formation forget
everything you ever know let God reveal
to you who he is and build a into um
your understanding who he is so well no
wonder yeah yeah but no wonder
everyone's got their own God basically
or their own experience yes yes so no
one is ever lost
[Music]
right all right uh if we were going to
put oh this is oh I think this is
Phyllis tickle she was an
emergent
um well leader she's deceased now but
she's written some books and she was
very uh proactive in ecumenical
movements so she says if one were going
to put one adjective to the great
emergence now listen to this great
emergence this sounds so new Agy and yet
this is the vocabulary of the emerging
Church emerging is what we're really
they're taking you out of the
traditional fundamental church and
they're going to deconstruct it and take
you to a New Age oul church is what's
going on it's what it's called the
emerging church right um and thereby one
out of two emerg emergence Christianity
would say
deinstitutionalized they do not like um
denominations that's why you're seeing
all these like around here we have no
longer have non- denominational per se
they are but they've taken on these
generic names like active Church
movement church and then you see Pulpit
swapping like even
here you have um active Church swapping
pulpits with crosswalk going back and
forth so and this is how they connect
with one another this is again direct
result of Vatican
2 all right so they want to change the
the traditional structure of the church
which was one of hierarchy you have your
pastors Elders deacons Deacon Etc a
respect of for the hierarchy they want
to flatten it this is why you hear you
don't hear people being called Pastor so
much anymore or their last names it's
like either their first name they'll
call them by or Pastor Bob Pastor whoop
whatever always first name because
they're just your buddy yeah yeah all
right the emerging Church the next thing
denominations are going to have to do
this is also philis tickle is join for
forces with each other which we are
seeing and I just gave an example of
that protestantism whatever else its
virtues are or were is enormously
divisive they don't like
division that that's got to stop the
concordant that new now exists between
the Lutheran Church and the Episcopal
Church is evidence in which they are
sharing pulpits next yes um just real
quick yes I don't know why I want to
clarify this for people who haven't
heard of Pulpit swapping or switching
because I had never heard of until I
experienced it and I was enraged
actually over it um so
suddenly in my church there
was
um just people of all different
denominations pastors from Catholic
churches from Lutheran Churches we even
had one Hindu man come in and he was all
of a sudden a guest speaker to stand at
the pulpit and give a sermon for that
week and I learned that you know as they
would declare it of later on that our
pastor was then going to go preach at
their Church they were swapping dates in
their each other's churches so that's
what that means and it's not how can you
declare all truth of all different
denominations um to be equal it's not
true
and I think that's what they're doing as
you're
saying yeah they're Breaking Down the
Walls the the walls of division and also
undermining your faith in the Bible and
what it says Uh there's an example um
honestly uh there's a church in um oh
it's like middle California I can't
think of the name of it but elm's Haven
if you're familiar with that
name that church they did a Pulpit Swap
and this
person led the congregation through a an
imaginative exercise a visualization
contemplated
exercise and this is how these things
come into the church they get introduced
little by little here and there this way
that way which we'll talk about so
that's that's the danger one of the
dangers um so Hallmark sign of
protestantism is divisiveness
divisiveness and deep intellectualism
heaven forbid you think that you use
your god-given brain right the Bible
says come let us
reason want reasoning when I started
realizing it was happening in the the
church they swapped not
only sermons that were deeply
intellectual but they swapped it for
sermons that were Fey touchy and more
like um just encouraging
emotional yes kind of they gave you an
experience yes yes and like you know we
know Disney teaches follow your heart so
this is just Disney and the
church okay um okay so then she says you
start talking about the atonement oh boy
they hate the atonement who else hates
the atonement Satan Satan right and
those who have spent their lives on the
Anselm Theory the penal substitution or
the individualized heaven or the sweet
Jesus by and bu they're are they're
going to be decimated educate educate
educate at the congregational level and
informed parish is not fearful in other
words um your in your ignorance you are
fear
F I see so the more they know that more
they'll not fear and they'll just kind
of give into it because you're telling
them it's okay yes and you're you've
developed this relationship with your
leaders now who you trust because
they're your friend they're not going to
steer you wrong and so that's another
influence that's a tug on the heart
you're like my my friend wouldn't lie to
me he's not going to take me the wrong
place or she at this point right um okay
so these are the books Phyllis tickle
wrote a the age of the spirit wonder
what spirit that is
right all right so
next uh Christianity accommodates
culture based on relative ideology not
the truth so detached decoy give them
something else talk about deconstruction
and then detour send them a different
direction and that's what's
happening so the emerging church is not
a denomination it's not a um a group it
is a thought is an IDE ology that is
penetrating the
churches yes and that's why well you the
rest later okay okay all right let's
sorry um no
worries woke more uh they have a woke
mentality we we seen that today yeah
really the the
culture of um the public sector is now
reflected in the church it's the same
woke
culture and morality is personal okay
next oh yeah okay so why are we seeing
this Alice Bailey if you're familiar
with her great if you're not she was a
theosophist an old cult theosophist and
channeled a lot uh she came up with a
10-point plan that the UN adopted when
they formed so number 10 is get
government governments to make all these
laws well should be laws oh all of these
law and get the church to endorse the
changes so our whole agenda make them a
law and then the church churches will
endorse what are we seeing now
churches sorry I went on I was gonna
answer it already yeah go I asked a
question so one um example I guess that
came to mind is we're seeing that the
whole lgbtq thing was passed into law
and then we saw a bunch of churches
starting to fly their
flag yes good point that's a really
strong example
yeah all right so God's true church
versus you know we can probably skip
through we'll just go fast okay what's
the difference between emerging church
and the true church God's true church
has Divine standards with universal
applications truth doesn't change it's
it applies to everything um they use a
unique name Baptist Methodist whatever
Catholic they everybody has a name and a
they're associated with a denomination
thereby a belief set of beliefs the
emerging Church identifies with the
culture it adapts it's built on change H
it prefers the neutral hip name like we
talked about okay
next and then God's true church a spirit
and the word of God convict of sin when
I was in spiritual formation for almost
N9 years I had no conviction of sin boy
when I came out of it and felt
conviction for the first time in years
it was not pretty you know it was
impactful and it's not meant to be
pretty it's meant to change us right yes
not to hold us in guilt that's Satan but
to wake us up and to cause us to reflect
and repent and turn away from okay the
emerging Church technology psychology
and marketing techniques which we'll
talk about later they're very big on
production uh Dramatics right they they
bring in
uh drama and dance and that sort of
thing they want to give you an
experience where the Holy Spirit the the
experience you get in the true church is
conviction all right next uh reliable
Bible yeah we use a Bible translation
one that is reliable you know now like
the emerging Church the message is Big
the NIV and the message and we know the
message is not a Bible that's a misnomer
it's a paraphrase and the gentleman who
wrote it practices contemplative prayer
among other things so it's not a safe
book to use right okay
next God's true church follows the Bible
instructions for reaching people with
the gospel in other words we believe in
the Three Angels
messages so we have a gospel to give
and
when we've been promised that when we
give it we will be empowered to give it
right yes so and it's for a reason it's
to it's a warning it's a call people out
of err so that they are not destroyed In
the End Amen I so that makes me think of
how many motivational talks they seem to
be switching to in their sermons but
God's message always has a purpose it is
supposed to divide not to make Division
and hardship but actually to make
someone decide whether they're going to
stand for him or
not
and it's beautiful in that way it's
supposed to feed you and give you
something and every time that they spoke
like that it gave me
nothing oh they gave you feelings good
feelings so you felt better about you
know continuing in your sins yes there's
no no there's no power in it for one
thing it's void of the power to change
which we know is damus right G
is power as well as forgiveness yeah um
so it's empty it's cheap Grace right
very yeah yes okay but you when you walk
out you feel like you've had an
experience and you're closer to God
which studies show um when people have
gone from this level up to this during
the service then afterwards when they
leave they go lower emotionally than
when they were yes so there's this
dopamine effect and then they have to
recover from that I've heard about that
effect I don't know what name they gave
it but so much depression with people
who actually go to churches where they
do that it's not that's another thing
it's almost the counterfeit of God's
word because God's word fills you and
you stay stable on it yes consistent
thread of Peace yes yes but the other
one creates an addiction you've got to
go back and go back and go back to get
that yes yeah
elevated okay next
okay God's true church uh stresses
growing in Grace uh you the you on
biblical Doctrine emerging Church
stresses the importance of great numbers
we want a bigger church this is your
mega church model and they're very much
into politics and contemp contemplative
spirituality uh as the guide for
spiritual life okay
next um God's true church is doctrinal
Purity and they are
fundamentalist and unity Freedom so you
have the freedom to choose or not choose
you don't find that in the emerging
church just as you experienced Aubrey
which I'm so sorry you went through that
um they love you and they show beautiful
affection you know love love love
until you speak truth to them and then
their faces grow cold yeah and you will
be ostracized and pushed out you will be
threatened you can't keep this position
anymore you're not welcome here Church
Church they will make sure that you do
not come back you will either change or
leave conform or and thank you yeah it
was a really rough experience but you're
summarizing it very well um it was
pretty
terrible and um they were actually
throwing people out of church they had
security guards that would just grab you
and throw you out the doors and you
would be asked never to come back again
um so
and you never saw Jesus doing that he
cleared the temple that was his father's
house but he cleared it of sin right
yeah not of Truth
tellers
oh um okay uh let's
see so yeah they want Unity at all cost
so not unity and truth and in life
application
messages more than Divine truth okay
next uh the church is separated from the
world music is to praise God sacredly in
the emerging church the church Embraces
the world and the music is to please and
attract so give them an experience give
them you know emotional roller coaster
and they'll be
back all right God's true church only
edifying hymns we talk about that okay
let's go to the next one
sorry um let's let's skip through past
these I think there's a kind of
redundant well I guess the important
piece was that the emerging church is
Christ is not the only way and in God's
true church Christ is the only way yes
so and then okay move
forward let's just move oh yeah okay so
the kingdom you can go back I'm sorry go
down to the bottom the kingdom uh is
here on Earth we know that God's kingdom
is not of this world right and we are
trying to share truth so that people can
be added to the kingdom
[Music]
an eternity one day right whereas
Kingdom of Earth is here and now and how
they expand is by accepting and
embracing and expanding so if you're a
witch I'll accept you I'm not going to
ask you to change who am I to tell you
to change you could be right I could be
wrong but that's that's what you believe
this is what I believe and we're we can
coexist and we'll just exist together so
come on in wow and that's that's how the
church
grows okay next in the
Kingdom all right
um okay big another big Point Church
does not like prophecy it says cold and
devoid of God's
love and I suppose being loving is
leaving them in error so that they they
can fall and be burned up in the end yes
I mean I don't even it defies logic so
but no don't upet the apple cart
yes yeah I mean it's
like it's like the church I experienced
they sto preaching um nothing about
Daniel or Revelation anymore Three
Angels
message um we don't want to scare people
right it was nothing hard-hitting
because those were
too mean almost of God to actually have
an absolute thought on something that he
wants you to know about so that you can
actually overcome
in fact there was no overcoming from my
own experience
um yeah people were just left to do
whatever they wanted stay in their sins
and just keep
going yeah and so we never will not be
prepared for Jesus when he comes back
right if that's you know the gospel that
we Embrace
yeah okay moving
on um let's see they're mood driven
instead of food driven they're coffee
driven though they like their coffee at
church okay so the the atmosphere will
be very relaxed a lot of them they just
take the pews out and they have cushions
or chairs or you know like a coffee shop
atmosphere really just come and be relax
we don't want to intimidate anybody we
don't want the
formalism and that's that's what happens
uh candles they love candles and that's
why you see all these darkened worship
Services wow I mean it's it's crazy
we'll talk about that later I have an
example too okay
next um socialization social justice
programs and just love people Jesus all
or just
Jesus um that's what they emphasize but
they Lop off the other half of his
character the Justice piece right and
they just they just uplift love and
that's a ditch you know they have they
have extracted part of his character and
only recognized
one that's not even biblical and they
like sermon Nets and now I was told um
by someone that their church just hired
a new pastor and they told them you have
seven minutes so they've gone from 20
minutes to 10 minutes down to seven
minutes but see that's a trajectory and
that's kind of towards the end of this
um presentation or this it's there's a
reason for that
aome all right um so the Lord is testing
his people to see who will be loyal to
the principles of his truth our work is
to Proclaim uh the first second and
third Angel's messages it's our duty we
are neither to despise nor to fear our
enemies to bind ourselves up by
contracts with those not of our faith is
not the order of God true we want to
save them we want to you know be
available if they have questions but if
they're trying to drag you
away then we do have to keep a safe
distance
spiritually but be available if they
ever change um see we are to treat
others with kindness and courtesy those
who refuse to be loyal to God but we are
never never to unite with them in
counsel and so those people who were who
were kicking people out of church that's
not even Christ's example that's not his
character to so to talk about love just
love and then to kick people out of the
church that's the fruit right there okay
next I I wanted to comment on that
actually because they even had people
get baptized and go
through quote unquote Bible studies
before doing so but they were not
thorough so those people by the time
they got baptized in a couple weeks went
by they actually said wait a minute what
did I get baptized into because they
started hearing about the Three Angels
message or about the Sabbath or
principles that this church was supposed
to uphold and they said wait that's not
what I signed up for so they actually
left
afterwards right what a huge disservice
to those people not even fair yes and I
thank God that I actually was raised
up in the truth all the way through up
until maybe my last years of high school
when this new pastor came in and started
doing these things I had already been
given a found Foundation to know what
was truth and what wasn't so I was just
seeing error tons of error and starting
to have the alarm Bells go off and go
okay this is wrong so thank God he God
for how you were raised yeah you had you
had that background that you could well
the Bible says test the spirits and what
you were hearing was not adding up so
you could see yes well those who had not
had that Foundation would never know or
see the error
exactly studying their scripture
themselves yes not only that but this is
why this topic is so important and I'm
really glad we're talking about it
because nobody else really is they're
almost seeing a big it's like the
elephant in the room that no one wants
to talk about why is there so much
division why are there too many
different denominations why do they all
act this way and yet we're all turning
our back on each other and seeing
certain
Trends and then we don't want to
actually admit what's what's the agenda
what's the trajectory
yeah yeah well we just want to talk
about God we don't talk about this stuff
right but when we don't talk about it as
you're seeing uh they just people follow
the error so what else do they have to
follow all right uh so utilize
storytelling those stories get to your
hearts so yeah all right
next
um so the emerging church was a set up
to be a Vanguard a forerunner to propel
the postmodern Evangelical Church
towards a paradigm shift this is the
detour we're talking about New Direction
um and structure methodology Theology
and purpose
next all right so let's talk about
leadership Network leadership Network
right you're familiar I so basically
this is a business
model that the church uh connected with
uh to build these mega churches this is
how they became mega churches so Peter
Ducker
um uh they they did an they did a
research on churches and what do the
people want so what they did was they
approached Church through a marketing
model rather than through a Biblical
truth model let's not give them truth
let's give them what they want so they
did research what do the people want whe
they wanted coffee they want to
socialize um they want to feel something
they like music so they said let's give
them what they want and that is
where this mega church emerging Church
feel Vibe comes from
yeah uh let's
see it's now I think it's called Global
Leadership
Network it's always changing right it's
all built on you can go to the next one
Mike
um okay so Phyllis took we're back to
huran termed the convergence with the
New Age The Great emergence so there you
go oh it's faith and practice practice
is practical application so what's the
practical application to all of this
well you help people you serve people
right uh let's see okay
next as more Christians become
influenced by Liber Liberation theology
they will also be drawn to the Marxist
analyst analysis and practice that is so
Central to the movement what have we
seen the past few years that very thing
it's like exactly so we're seeing the
fruit in the Church of the emerging
Church influence okay
next so Bob Buford and Peter Dreer
started this in
1984 um the leadership network network
was born did you have a question yes I
just have Peter duer his name keeps
going off in my head isn't he linked to
some other kind of
movement Rick Warren right he was Rick
Warren's
Mentor for many many years and you will
see I think some things reflected in
here with that that explains a lot
because at the church I was at the
pastor would say my biggest role model
is Rick Warren and all of a sudden my
family went who is he and we looked him
up and we're like hm and none of these
signs were starting to show yet of these
changes and we just went oh maybe he's a
good guy I don't know yeah wow that's
the thing about this it's so subtle it's
like well I'll give you an example when
we get there okay um so this whole
movement was built on the psychosocial
change theory you go the next
one they they first started working with
the
leaders which we see now um they will
connect with conferences and have
they'll host weekends leadership
weekends for uh the pastors and such
your conference leaders and pastors and
then they they will take what they
learned and go back to their churches
and take it to the churches yes that
happened so much at that church that I
was at that um sorry I'll make it quick
but they were even taking young people
and starting to send them to to these
leadership conferences and um would pay
everything
and ironically
they were the kids of usually and I hate
to be the person say this but they were
the children usually of the most
affluent families in the church as
well well you know just as the Catholic
church is f focus on the youth and the
Jesuits this is
really a Jesuit model in a lot of ways
so if they can change the church and the
youth then I I have to say about myself
we old people will die off they're
they're ready for the gray hairs to move
on and they've already because we're in
the way right they just want the youth
so and I had a pastor who said that at
our church whoa so because we we and the
even older ones we would always block
certain movements yes and they like well
eventually these people are going to die
off and that's the mentality yeah they
die off and kill off all the people or
not really they don't kill them off but
they're hoping they'll die off quick so
that they won't know better nobody will
be present to know better anymore yeah
or stop their
agendas okay so this was really a
substitute for the genuine Holy Spirit
Revival and now the emergent leaders U
many of the leadership Network leaders
were new age and brought in such practi
practitioners and Satan worshippers to
speak to them so these these leaders who
were bringing things to the churches
were themselves entertaining these kinds
of things so let's you can move to the
next one Peter duer was a proponent of
Eastern mysticism beli that everyone is
what one with God should be a unified
Force to bring all religions together so
we have monism pantheism what however
you want to name that and then everyone
just needs to all come together okay
next
um Martin Boer
thus a Divine spark lives in everything
and being but each spark is enclosed by
an isolating shell our bodies are the
shell the spark is what's inside so
we're all Divine this is why they don't
talk about sin because you don't sin you
are God oh wow which yeah this not
upfront but eventually it leads to that
okay mentality and teaching okay
next Oh see it needs to be uh it needs
the Deep experience that thou and and
the I are one which all higher religions
share oh there you go so your
fundamentalist is not going to believe
this so we're kind of in the way but
this is what they're trying to get the
fundamentalist to believe okay so Peter
Ducker says even a stool needs three
legs religion government and business
and they are to work together oh no when
you think about prophecy you have you
have your Merchants you have you know
your religion your government they're
all working together yes okay next now
he also says the Third Leg of the stool
is the churches there's a public sector
role there's a private sector role and
there's a faith sector
role right so there's the setup sorry
forgive me um so this makes me think of
Kellogg
um I hope I have this right but when he
started going more into the new age and
preaching certain things in the
documents that they were going to to
actually print um I think that Printing
House burned down
living yes they were warned he was
warned yes and he was going to print it
anyway and there was divine intervention
yes so when you sell out and you try to
do it based on money or numbers and fame
there's always a
consequence and what he was bringing to
people oh yeah who had trusted him so
that influence hopefully was broken at
least for a
time okay so go on to the next
sorry we meet with the government
leaders we meet with the Business
Leaders and we meet with the pastors we
train the pastors but we also meet with
those other legs of the stool so that
they understand they have to bring the
churches to the table Church to the
table so they're working in the churches
and then they're trying to work with the
other pieces of that stool to bring
everybody together wow even that
language bring everyone to the table
that was spoken so much that exact
verbage from where I came oh yeah see
yeah they have a
language for sure when you pick up on
those little words that you know but
it's also changing too because they
don't want to be identified all right
the rise and development of the emerging
Church movement became such a
significant collaborator and delivery
system for the major paradigm shift that
has affected and infiltrated the mindset
of the many Evangelical pastors the
shift includes the notion that the
church must become postmodern in order
to reach secular America in other words
they have to change or they won't exist
either and I think some leaders have
said that okay
next all right shift includes a
definitive move away from belief in
absolute truth which we've talked about
right um retreat by many from the belief
that the Bible is without
error okay next right M undermining your
faith in the Bible is what they're doing
slow
breakdown remember it's a deconstruction
movement so duker says uh duker was
intrigued with the mega church from a
specifically social sociological
economic point of view and the mega
church would be just fine as long as it
was par um pragmatically meeting the
felt needs of the people um the
spiritual beliefs of a particular mega
church were really not a concern he
didn't care about the beliefs he just
wanted everybody have an experience and
come together okay
next so it was it made sense to him that
the ambience of the mega church should
be above all Seeker friendly after all
his personal pursuit of spirituality was
fulfilled in kite guard and Eastern
mysticism okay
next so I heard that sorry I heard that
verbage as well it was always Seeker
friendly Seeker friendly make it Seeker
friendly yeah so you know the things
they were reading and the people were
influencing them when you when you hear
that
yes wow okay Bob eord was also part of
leadership Network he says his previous
oh his website endorsed occultists and
Mystics like Jim Collins taking a new AG
spiritual course contacting Spirit
guides using tarot cards for spiritual
guidance whoa so this is these are the
leaders influencing the churches okay
next okay um so they're focused on unity
and worldwide
Oneness between eastern and western
cultures and thinking all right
next okay let's let's pass through this
this just kind of goes through the
history you know what leadership network
does so we can go forward
okay uh we can forward through this too
okay and this
one this is the beginning of the mega
church tell who the team leaders were
you know we are like in second third
generation now mhm so you know it's not
as re relevant um so Rob Bell he's an
emergent leader said that this is not
just a same old message with new methods
we're discovering Christianity as an
Eastern religion as a way of life oh so
again this this Collision of
Christianity with the new age right and
Eastern mysticism okay next
okay oh this one Tony Jones says we must
stop looking for some objective truth
that is available when we uh delve into
the text of the Bible don't look for
truth okay next yeah it gets worse okay
next I I'm quite convinced that the
Bible is a subversive text I think the
Bible is a scary book I think that
deconstruction is the only hermeneutical
Avenue wow these are your leaders your
church leaders influencing our church
leaders okay
next um and then we're told for it will
not come unless the apostasy comes first
right wow apostasy is woven through our
churches okay next okay but so is truth
because there are people in the churches
the wheat and The Tear grow together
right uh let's see
okay so Brian Mclaren he sums it up
pretty good I must add though that I
don't believe making disciples must
equal making adherence to the Christian
religion so you can be anything yeah and
this is what I saw played out in
spiritual formation in my classes for
Spiritual direction for those three
years wow okay
next uh the Jesus of one reading of the
Apocalypse brings us to a grim
resignation and the world will get worse
and worse and finally the G this
jihadist Jesus will return to use Force
domination violence and even torture the
ultimate imper Imperial tools to
Vanquish evil and bring peace oh wow at
him they Mar his character when in
reality who is doing that now
to to God's people to God's
word okay next yeah
okay there we go all right let's
see so we're told in second Timothy
indeed all who desire to live Godly in
Christ Jesus will be persecuted but evil
men and imposters will proceed from bad
to worse deceiving and being deceived so
he's right about that things are going
to get worse but characters are being
changed so there'll be two groups when
Jesus comes back the righteous and and
the wicked M so the wicked will be
fullon Wicked and the righteous will be
righteous yes so two images being
formed okay
next now we can go through this we don't
need new Brian clear is he um he's an
author Oh Oh I thought I okay forward
forward forward I thought I skipped some
of these
slides skip okay okay uh David Spangler
okay yeah this is a good one so he says
any old Christ will not do not if we
need to show that we have something
better than the mainstream Christian
Traditions it must be a cosmic Christ a
universal Christ a new age Christ wow so
he agrees with philis
tickle okay
next he also says Lucifer the angel of
man's evolution is leading man to Cosmic
Consciousness and godhead oh so he
showed you which Cosmic
Christ Y and that's no different than
the catechism I don't think I added that
into this this one but there are three
quotes in the catechism that says you
will become you will become God you will
become as Gods you will become Christ
wow and just really quick everybody's in
agreement who um who is David's B just a
brief oh now you stumped me oh no no
he's like a well let's Google him I
don't want to missp speak uh you know
who brought this to me um that that
particular Slide the rest of Mind was um
Eric Wilson okay does he claim to be a
Christian perhaps I have to look and see
I think that he is and he's more of an
emergent obviously so let's see who he
is let's see I don't want to misspeak
okay is an American spiritual
philosopher and self-described practical
Mystic he helped transform the fin fum
foundation in Northern Scotland into a
center of residential and spiritual
education
okay so there you
go that explains it remember the Jesuits
are heavy into philosophy too so we
don't
know I mean everybody in agreement where
wherever they're coming from they're all
you know they use philosophy to
undermine okay
next all right Christ is the same Force
as Lucifer Lucifer prepares the man for
the experience of
christh so I mean you know he's agreeing
with Alice Bailey and loty okay next
right uh we've seen enough I think of
okay he also says Lucifer Works within
each of us to bring us to wholeness as
we move toward the new age to the new
age yeah well he doesn't live in he
doesn't work in me I hope yes I don't I
don't receive that but this is their
perspective okay next that does sound
like blaty right
there okay next next
okay um
okay so McClaren cites Dallas Willard
and Richard Foster with their emphasis
on spiritual disciplines as the key
mentors of the emerging church so you
have people who are
following um the spiritual exercises of
lyola and um this is this is influencing
them so none of these thinkers has any
inclination to throw out the baby of
Truth with the bathwater of M modernity
in other words you know we're not going
to throw out truth or keep we're not
going to focus on
truth there's going to be a mix you know
wow black and white okay here's an
example of maybe an emerging Church you
walk in the music is so loud there's
earplugs you can just grab your earplugs
and go in um they have uh coffee bars
Baristas um right for you okay next okay
darkened worship services right yeah
very dark and they have smoke machines
too oftentimes not everybody not
everybody has that kind of money MH
but and then this is Leonard sweet okay
connecting with one of our churches one
of the Protestant churches and he's also
been to Protestant universities to speak
oh wow and this is what they throw up on
the screen and this is a you know
Catholic Christ H wow among other things
maybe it's hard to but it wasn't exactly
right so that's what they gets projected
with all this music
and such okay next
okay oh of course you're gonna have that
drums yeah and then
next all right so Charles Coulson says
um the spread of the charismatic through
songs prayers and worship Styles going
well beyond officially charismatic
circles has done a great to reduce the
barriers between Catholics and
evangelicals wow this is a result of
proest of um Vatican 2 so even through
music we they're
evangelizing okay next okay so we're
told a new organization would be written
intellectual philosophy would replace
the fundamental truths of the church the
Sabbath would be lightly regarded and
the New Movement would be spearheaded by
aggressive men who would allow nothing
to stand in the way mhm you experience
Miss Aubrey yes okay
next uh so the results is um this
influence is a growing willingness
willingness to accept dreams as a
reliable channel of divine communication
so every replaces the Bible my
experience will replace the Bible if I
get a guide or um another person or if I
have a dream or a vision then that's my
truth it's a direct experience rather
than reading from the Bible someone
else's experience that's indirect so not
as credible yeah they say there's a
strong emphasis on Interfaith dialogue
this is um your candid
conversations yes so you can go to these
meetings and they'll have a little
sermon or a talk and then they break out
into these table sessions and whether's
a table Monitor and they have these
discussions and you're only allowed to
talk about what they want to talk about
yes I did see it's a way to break
mhm
yeah yeah strong emphasis on tolerance
and being non-judgmental unless it's
truth then they're very intolerant of
Truth and very judgmental okay next
okay let's see results of emerg and New
Age influence a marked reluctance to
condemn apostasy or even address it
which you're you experience they don't
want to talk about it yeah uh and Mark
reluctance to warn of demonic and occult
influences in the world today what are
we seeing being manifested so I mean
some people aren't able to identify that
as oppression or harassment but without
that understanding they never will so
how do they engage in spiritual warfare
yes and I I don't know if people really
want to know but they are using since
you said um harassment and so on we had
intimidation ation tactics tactics
coercion um threats there was all kinds
of things happening and so I just don't
know how they operated but now it's
making a lot more sense um thanks to you
unfortunately it makes me just really
sad also it is it's heartbreaking I mean
I had to leave a previous church I was
there were things happening in the back
that I never really told anybody you
know and when it comes to physical
assault right
no right we're done we're done here so
there you go you just have
to
um move when the spirit
leads knowing that you've done all you
can do and it's in God's hands yes right
he's still overse he walking Revelation
depicts him walking among his churches
so he moves someone somewhere else and
they can be a blessing there and be
blessed and he'll bring up another
person who maybe can start fresh right
so
yeah um
okay what else okay next
okay H okay Revelation says uh 146 and 7
says and I saw another angel fly in the
midst of Heaven having the Everlasting
gospel to preach to them that dwell on
the earth this is what we are to be
preaching to Every Nation here's your
globalism right every nation and Kindred
and tongue and people saying with a loud
voice we've got to be able to speak up
clearly loudly and give it a certain
tone so that you know the Holy Spirit
can bring forth conviction and
understanding fear God and give glory to
him right are we giving Glory when we
shut our mouths when we quit giving the
messages he was when we leave people in
sin and error and
destruction no so um we are to worship
Him who the
Creator we we we don't follow anybody
else these people did not create
us okay so next
okay um Al that we can move forward
okay um okay okay so that's the emerging
church so now we they've undermined our
fundamental beliefs they've changed
their way of thinking they changed our
worship is built on change and we have
shorter sermets you know based on
feelings
emotionalism
and now we're moving towards convergence
we're emerging out of and now what are
they bringing us to good question what
is the point of all this so dardine
who was Jesuit um said after emergence
comes immersion so let's look at that
mm all right what is Convergence it is
the coming together of three major
historic branches of the church the
sacramental Evangelical and charismatic
oh wow they've done away with the
fundamentalists so now they want to
bring everybody together and honestly
it's they really there's a big Eucharist
push right now um to get everybody
celebrating the Eucharist and again they
hate the atonement so it appears that
they love the atonement but every time
they put Jesus back on the cross and
raise him again right because the priest
has the power to do it
supposedly so which ex which makes sense
when they are God they can bring life
right so I didn't understand that until
the last couple weeks and I'm like Lord
I don't understand why why this why this
Eucharist and that's what it is they are
now God they take his place okay
Evangelical scripture ad Mission
charismatic fesal okay what is
Convergence the conver convergence
movement has identified the three living
streams of the church and invites God to
bring them together as one complete and
living a lifegiving river okay
wow Quinton Moore um he's a bishop
Quinton Moore says these three streams
each in their own way have defined the
map of Christianity Through the Ages and
will merge like a flood into the future
to bring
reconciliation and unleash God's
powerful purposes
this is a false Revival movement is what
we're GNA see and we're seeing those now
they're popping up we are it's huge
and it's hard because I feel like they
are talking about this River that's
carrying everyone
into kind of like floating down a lazy
river where nothing is bad and
everything's acceptable but really that
water is Tainted it's going to kill us
eventually it's to your demise to stay
there it's I mean it's really sneaky of
them for one but I think a lot of people
aren't seeing it for
sure no and they're not being encouraged
to look bigger you know they're they're
content with all their emotional
experiences and and fluff they don't
know it's fluff you if you've never
experienced something you don't miss it
right
well we need to pray for these people
right because God has his people every
he brought me out right so he can bring
other people out it really the there's
power and intercessory prayer and there
again you're back to your spiritual
warfare what is the church talking about
spiritual
warfare so yeah all right so next
slide okay conversions to move towards
one point to come together or to meet
for far too long the church has been
divided and separated from one another
Christ is not divided into parts and
neither can his body be
divided uh in Matthew 12:24 he warned
any Kingdom that is divided against
itself is being brought to Desolation
and laid waste so there's like a threat
here a warning um that's going to make
you fearful right so they're using fear
and yet it's not coming together in
spirit and in truth there's another
Spirit driving this and it's not even
truth okay next slide
okay he also says as members of the body
of Christ we are powerless as long as we
are filled with prejudice or and
disharmony agreement brings power does
the Bible say about praying an
agreement we're supposed to pray in
agreement right where two or three are
gathered and um he is there
and so but this is a counterfeit of that
and
so people will be unifying mhm one group
will be unifying in truth another group
will be unifying in error so truth
divides but it also
unifies yes and I think it's really
important for people to understand that
when God says to come together and be
United that's the very verse that they
are using to usually fuel this entire
movement and Ste ahead and guilt you for
not coming in line yeah
you know so what's wrong with
you don't you want to be in agreement
don't you want God's power right don't
you want to be part of the body of
Christ okay next
okay uh let's see so their ideology says
conventional comforting Christian
Christianity has
failed um it does not work for the
churches that insist on preaching it The
Jig Is up we cannot go back and we
should not want to in earlier American
Awakenings preachers extoled oldtime
religion and the answer to questions
about God morality and existence this
Awakening is different okay
next it is not about saw us Trails
mortification of sin putting to death
The Old Man and being washed in the
blood of the Lamb the preaching of the
Cross emphasize oh anyway that's what
what it means The Awakening going on
around us is not an Evangelical Revival
is not returning to the Faith of Our
followers or recreating our grandparents
church instead it is the great returning
to ancient understandings of the human
quest for the Divine
wow so don't follow God be
God okay
next okay so you know we have the Ten
Commandments
um love your neighbor as yourself love
God
um there's they have three oh you can go
back sorry back okay yeah so they have
love God love your neighbor love self oh
I mean how can that be even a an
ideology or a commandment so this is
this is convergent Church um wow
Foundation right here okay next
WoW all right they're letting go of oh
this is from Darkwood Brew this is a an
emerging convergence kind of coffee sh
platform um blog says they are letting
go of empty worship conventions and an
overemphasis on doctors doctrines as
tools of division and exclusion so cast
us just Cast Away Doctrine right they
are embracing more d uh diversive
creative engaging approaches often
making strong use of the Arts so as I
said earlier uh sermons are now becoming
shorter and
shorter eventually there may be no
sermon at all
the experience you may get is to walk in
and people are doing this um
denominations are doing this you walk
into church and they might have art they
might have table set up one with poetry
one with a um any kind of art A Relic a
cross or a picture a drawing and you go
and you
contemplate wow at those tables and
that's your worship experience but it's
a contemplative kind of worship
experience and there is no preaching
there's no Truth at all you've seen
this yes oh
wow well I mean have you ever seen have
you ever seen dance interpretation in
the churches that's a strong example
Yeah dance
teams same
thing uh they the music can be highbrow
you know the
um um violin cello anything like that it
can be um rock it can be it's like this
Collision or collusion of all of these
different pieces and within a service
you can have any or all the
above right okay
next oh did I get it no
okay okay okay they are letting go of
the desire to impose their particular
version of Faith to to on a wider
Society so in other words don't tell
your truth don't tell don't don't teach
truth right don't impose your your views
they're embracing the notion that their
purpose is to make themselves more
faithful adherence of their version of
Faith remember this is love of
self okay
next they are letting go of Notions of
the afterlife that are dominated by
Judgment of unbelievers so there's no
judgment they're embracing an
understanding that as God's creations
I don't know how we can be created if
we're God anyway God is eternally
faithful to us and that all people are
loved far more than we can comprehend so
because of his love and faithfulness to
us that's all we need there we don't
have to return
that yeah that's the whole other half
puzzle yeah we're loving self God loves
me I love me okay
next okay they are letting go of old
hierarchies that priv privilege
religious leaders overlay people they're
embracing an understanding that all
people have a mission and purpose in
life in response to the call of the holy
spirit it's no longer about who wears
the robes but who lives the lives again
the flattening of the hierarchy okay
next
okay uh velvet Elvis this is a book by
Rob Bell it says to make the cross of
Jesus just about human salvation is to
miss that God is interested in Saving of
everything every Star and rock and bird
all things oh wow pantheism
pantheism okay he's coming to he's going
to destroy this Earth yes yeah right so
he's he's coming to save people okay oh
you can move forward okay sorry no
worries uh let's see all right well this
is a positive one I guess it
substantiates what we're reading the
warnings of the word of God regarding
the perils surrounding the Christian
Church belong to us today as in the days
of the Apostles men Tried by tradition
and philosophy to destroy faith in the
scriptures so today by higher criticism
Evolution spiritualism theosophy and
pantheism the enemy of righteousness is
seeking to lead Souls into the Forbidden
paths oh wow yeah and the emergent would
consider it ancient paths I love to use
the word anent okay next
okay okay Brian Mclaren says drop any
Affair you may have with certainty proof
argument and replace it with dialogue
conversation Intrigue and
search question question and just you
know never come to a point of
um absolute truth yes you have to doubt
always doubt always question always
search
okay
next um okay we can go forward
okay all right Teasdale he was a monk uh
Wayne teale he says um who coined the
term
interspirituality and he says
interspirituality is the spiritual
common ground which exists among the
world's
religions how does this happen right
okay next
okay te says she the church also has a
responsibility in our age to be a bridge
for reconciling the Human family the
spirit is inspiring her through the sins
of the times signs of the times excuse
me uh through the signs of the times to
open to Hindus Buddhists Muslims siks
Janes taist confucians and Indigenous
people um when I was sitting in class in
my spiritual formation and spiritual
Direction days I had a witch on one side
I had I know agnostic over here I had
Christian Science over there and we were
told not to judge it it
impedes the um spiritual Direction
sessions uh you just accept them where
they are and and leave them where they
are you're just here to serve them
yeah so and many of my instructors were
reading Buddhist books and I asked one
one day I said you're a Christian how
can you Embrace Buddhism she says I
don't see there's a conflict wow and
they don't
yeah my spiritual director had um
Buddhist or whatever prayer
beads and icons Catholic icons as well
like there's this interp spirituality
going on
okay um let's see next
okay the Christian is not to become a
Hindu or Buddhist nor Hindu a Buddhist
to become a Christian but each other or
each must assimilate the spirit of the
others I don't know about you but I
don't want any of those Spirits no no
right crazy that is so
scary
yes and okay go ahead
okay instead oh this is Alice Bailey
instead of opposing Christianity the
occult would capture and blend itself
within Christianity and then use it as
its primary vehicle for spreading and
instilling new agage
Consciousness the various churches would
still have their outer trappings of the
Christian of Christianity and still use
much of the same lingo next
WoW if asked certain questions about
traditional Christian doctrine the same
answers would be given but it would all
be on the outside this is your e
exoteric right outside what people
believe and see on the outside and on
the inside a contemplative spirituality
would be drawing in those open to it so
this is your
esoteric model
yes okay
next she says um the new era is coming
the new ideals the new civilization the
new modes of Life of Education of and we
see that today of religious presentation
and of government are slow okay look at
that what's the three-legged stool right
there are um slowly precipitating and
not can stop them they can however be
delayed by the reactionary types of
people by the ultra conservative and
closed minds they are the ones who can
and do hold back the hour of Liberation
these must all be brought under the
power of death whoa and what was it that
Wayne tasel the monk said the Christian
of the future will be a Mystic or he
will not exist at all yes the pope also
says something more in line of Alis a
Bailey I need to get that quote I just
heard it today um but he agrees and now
we have an occultist saying the same
thing they need to be killed and so when
you think about Revelation 133 a death
decree coming you can see how that can
easily be imposed yes and you can
see so clearly they're on the same team
They're all playing by the same rules
and Liberation is their agenda
supposedly but um that Liberation is
from the Bible it's not to adhere to the
Bible at all or God's word or God we we
find Freedom in Christ right he's our
sin Bearer he's he's our way maker he's
everything he we don't have to have a
burden we can be free in him and who he
sets free is free indeed when you're in
this you are um you are owned yeah and
oftentimes they will Satan you know will
put thoughts in your head and try to
kill you every most everybody who's
engaged in in these kinds of things ends
up dying in a horrible death
self-induced oftentimes wow because we
give our mind over to another spirit
right
wow all right so the next we're coming
to a close people I promise yes it's
okay but it's so worth it okay okay and
they can watch
later okay in spirituality and Alice
Bailey this Unity of spiritual thought
would not be a single one world
denomination but would have a unity in
diversity Multicultural Interfaith
ecumenical agenda there it is so this is
why we do not proti
other other groups we accept Embrace and
expand the Kingdom Here and Now and
everybody just comes
together right so
next uh let's see throw out any idea of
historical Jesus we should focus on the
cosmic Christ who is defined as the
pattern that connects so they're just
telling you here we're swapping Jesus
out for another
Jesus all right and says Divinity wants
to
um birth the cosmic Christ in each and
every
individual the cosmic Christ connects
every part of creation and every part of
heaven with Earth Divinity and Humanity
so this is pantheism
pantheism
right okay all right next so number nine
of Alice a Bailey's 10-point plan we
already talked about number 10 so number
nine is create an Interfaith movement
promote other faiths to be at par with
Christianity and break this thing about
Christ chran it as being the only way to
Heaven by that Christianity will be
pulled down and other faiths promoted
yeah it will okay
next okay that might be the end let's
see
um so okay the sayings and doings of men
are dwelt upon instead of the plain
cutting truths of the word of God the
spirit and friendship of the world are
at enmity with God
when the truth in its Simplicity and its
strength as it is in Jesus is brought to
bear against the spirit of the world it
at once awakens the spirit of
persecution and then said the angel
nothing less than the whole armor of
righteousness can enable man to overcome
the powers of darkness and refra retain
um the victory over them this is why we
have to know our Bibles we have to be in
the word we need to learn spiritual
warfare biblical spiritual warfare yes
my weapons are not of this world
right so we can go to the next and see
if there's what's there if there's
anything I'm not sure
okay okay Teasdale he's a monk uh he
says as Matrix a binding substance the
church would no longer see members of
other Traditions as outside her life she
would promote the study of these
Traditions seek common ground and
parallel insights okay next oh wow this
is
syncretism yes excellent good job uh the
final outcome of contemplative prayer is
interspirituality so how could all those
different religions Christian and
non-christians come together on
mysticism right the Christian of the
future will be a Mystic or he will not
exist at all it's through contemplative
prayer I.E meditation if you're a witch
meditation if you're a new Ager Etc it's
all the same they're coming together on
one piece and it's uniting wow okay next
okay um Divinity is in all things and
the presence of God is in all religions
there's a connecting together of all
things and through mysticism this state
of divinity can be
recognized
wow and then next
MH uh okay as the followers of Christ
gradually United with them the
Christianity religion or Christian
religion became corrupt and the church
lost its power and Purity worldly
customs and practices are introduced
because the hearts of unconsecrated
ministers and church members still cling
to the love of the world yes next so
again it's self-love if I love me my
wants more than truth I'm going to let
anything
in but truth
uh okay so there's a difference
between oh boy okay I thought we were
done we're not quite done yet so
convergent church and hell what does the
convergent Church believe about hell
this is one of the huge problems with
the traditional understanding of hell
because if the cross is in line with
Jesus's teaching then I won't say the
only and I certainly won't say or even
the primary or primary meaning of the
Cross is the kingdom of God doesn't come
like the kingdom of This World by
inflicting violence and coercing people
go ahead okay but that the kingdom of
God comes through oh oh suffering that's
not a good okay that blue piece is
suffering and willing voluntary
sacrifice right so they're talking about
the sacrifice Jesus made or God made for
his son they don't like the sacrifice so
this is what you're talking about okay
next okay but I didn't and ironic
way the do the doctrine thank you the
doctrine of Hell basically says no
that's not really true at the end God
gets his way through coercion and
violence and intimidation and domination
just like every other kingdom does the
Cross isn't the center then the cross is
almost a distraction and false
advertising for God okay
next for Jesus this is Rob Bell for
Jesus has Heaven and Hell were present
realities ways of living we can enter
into here and now he talked very little
of the life beyond this one okay next
WoW says s Brian also said on a radio
show if the doctrine of hell is true
Brian Mclaren says that God is asking us
to do something he can't do himself
forgive
what right that the doctrine of hell is
true so if he's going to destroy people
then obviously he can't he can't forgive
oh no justice is part of his right hand
you gota yeah but he's just love I know
he's just love no isn't that sad okay
next okay so let's look at wiah why am I
bringing Wick into this we'll see let's
unpack it a little bit Yeah so defined
as the religious Cult of modern
witchcraft you can be Wiccan and not
practice witchcraft you can be Wiccan
and you can be a Christian it's okay
wiah is a religion of the elements and
of the earth herself we celebrate the
Earth and her beauty so we have Earth
worship right and syncretism you can be
this or that okay
next wias Creed all good that a person
does to another returns three-fold in
this life oh harm is also returned
three-fold this is important to us this
reminds us not to cause harm what did I
think it was Brian m say a few minutes
ago it's either Rob Bell or Brian
Mclaren that um hell hell and heaven are
here oh yeah right so if I'm good to you
I'm bringing heaven to you if I'm
treating you badly and bringing hell to
you right and then there's Karma it's
that so we have an
agreement yes we have an
agreement with of um the convergence
Church
with
wiah okay okay
next witches generally believe that
heaven and hell are all around us all
the time depending on how we live we
create heaven in this in the world and
we create hell in the world by our
actions and choices Jesus also seemed to
believe this the Kingdom of Heaven is
within you for instance the kingdom of
God is all around you right here and now
he said this is a Twist of his words
yeah okay next okay same beliefs they
both practice contemplative prayer wikas
are alpha it's they use Alpha that's
meditation um BR in contemplative prayer
is Alpha brain waves so they don't
believe in heaven no hell no judgment
and Truth is determined by me oh one and
the
same
yes all right next
MH all right so the conversion church
you can be a Christian and Buddhist Etc
do good to others social justice Heaven
and Hell or right now in how we treat
people wi you can be Wicked and
Christian you do good to others that's
your social justice piece heaven and
hell are right here how we treat people
okay
next so deconstruction in a nut cell a
nutshell it says it was his policy to
proplex with subtle arguments concerning
the purpose of God everything that was
simple he shrouded in my
and by Artful perversion cast out upon
the plainest statements of
Jehovah okay
next they disputed over insignificant
technicalities and practically denied
the most essential truths thus
infidelity was soon
broadcast God's word was robbed of its
power and evil spirits worked their will
next but they did not destroy the
Nations concerning whom the Lord
commanded them but were mingled among
the the heaven the Heathen and learned
their works and they served their Idols
which were a snare unto them and we're
seeing this happening today yes okay
next so many the Bible is a lamp without
oil because they have turned their minds
into channels of speculative belief that
bring misunderstanding and confusion the
work of higher criticism is destroying
faith in the Bible as divine revelation
it is robbing God's word of power to
control uplift and Inspire human lives
by spiritualism multitudes are taught to
believe that desire is the highest law
the license is liberty and that man is
accountable only to himself next
true let the world go into spiritualism
into theosophy into
pantheism if they choose we are to have
nothing to do with the deceptive
branches of Satan's Work O
wow yeah and next but evil men and
seducers shall wax worst to see oh we
already talked about that okay
next those who give their affections to
any leader this is another problem when
we form these alliances these heart ties
with leaders who don't deserve our heart
tie should be with God we can appreciate
leaders we can have a fondness for them
but the minute eror is spoken we need to
be able to be in a position to call
error By Its Right name
Amen to give affections to any leader
but Christ will find themselves under
the the control Body and Soul and Spirit
of an infatuation that is so entrancing
that under its power Souls turn away
from hearing the truth to believe a lie
they're in stared and taken and by their
every action they cry release unto us
barabus but crucify
Christ all right next true Unity if
Unity could be secured only by the
compromise of Truth and righteousness
then let there be difference difference
a difference and even
War do not be conformed to this world
but be transformed by the renewal of
your mind that by testing you may
discern what is the will of
God what is good and acceptable and
perfect yes okay next
um therefore hearken not to your
prophets nor to your divers nor to your
dreamers nor to your enchanters nor to
your Sorcerers which speak unto you
saying ye shall not serve the king of
Babylon remove you far from you L remove
you far from your land and that I should
drive you out and ye should perish okay
next take heed unto thyself and unto the
doctrine continue in them for in doing
this thou th shalt both save thyself and
them that hear thee this is why we have
to speak amen
yeah okay
next Christ will be represented in the
person of those who accept the truth and
who identify their interest with that of
their
lord and I will bring them and they
shall dwell in the midst of Jerusalem
and they shall be my people and I will
be their God in truth and righteousness
I think I know there may be more oh
that's
that you want to know more about mystify
about mysticism check us out on
mystified film.com from um LIF streams
media yes it is her story but it's a
good one and you learn more about it um
there's items there I'm sure that we
have not covered we could probably have
another show covering some of the very
symbolism and ritualistic items that
were used in practices um let us know if
you would like
that I don't know how much you want to
talk about
but oh I'll whatever you want um for any
future program just let me know okay
perfect um I'll let you go ahead and
promote that um fully if you
want promote that what that movie there
oh I did mystified so it's about it
started out is my testimony in spiritual
formation and Maring church and coming
out and then more was added to it uh
because that's how this is the more you
get into it the deeper it is the more
expansive it is and so it tells about
Vatican 2 it talks about mysticism um
the the practices it also brings in Sam
and Val story uh searching for God and
trying all sorts of different things
we're now seeing um these
hallucinogenics brought being brought
into the churches as an experience MH uh
as a method of healing uh Old Wounds and
such so they experienced that not as
Christians but um as Seekers trying to
figure out things
and and then uh Vala during one of her
experiences asked the shaman or told the
shaman she wanted to know truth he's
like what is it you want from this she
says I want truth I want the
truth and that begins their Journey out
of these things so all of this stuff
seems separate but it's kind of
collision it's come together the
churches are doing mushrooms and and
henics the world is doing this um and so
it's not just about that but you can see
there's a labyrint there's contemplative
pieces there's there's so many things
it's like a bicycle wheel with spokes it
converges this is your convergence so it
it unpacks all of that wow it sounds
really good I'm
intrigued well thank you guys for
hanging in there this has been great I
hope it's been very insightful to you as
it was to me and of course to Stephanie
throughout her
experience please um like And subscribe
and hopefully we'll have a lot more um
and go look at Stephanie's Channel as
well if you would and subscribe to hers
she's got a lot of good resources there
more
information but this is just we need to
know about this deception we need to be
able to see what the truth is as
Stephanie's so aptly said we have to
know the truth the truth will set us
free the truth is everything and only
thing we can stand on so I hope you've
heard that and the heart cry of both of
us I think
it's quite touching actually to talk
about this it's um really sad and
so I hope you
guys enjoyed but I hope you understand
now thank you for tuning in oh this is
very personal to Aubrey and Aubrey I'm
so sorry for all that you went
through thank you and um you were right
and God was using you and he's still
using your example today and he's I'm
sure will bring others has already
brought others to um say the things that
they need to hear so encourage my friend
and pray for these people they're in
bondage they don't understand
and so um you know and now maybe you can
be a force for good spiritually in
spiritual warfare so need and God is
caring for you and your heart and um the
good that you're doing to expose this
thank you so it's important to know
truth but if we don't know some of this
stuff we don't need to steep ourselves
in it like I had to um in coming out to
try to teach others um but we need to
know something of it because it is so
sneaky yes so don't avoid studying this
don't make it your primary but don't
avoid it because you might be the eyes
for someone
else very true who's in
need well thank you so much for all that
you shared and your kind
words and um thank you guys all for
tuning in and watching and I hope you
guys have a good night all right yes
thanks for watching good night God bless
you all thank you YouTube